je vais vous rendre votre devoir sur
table
alors vous êtes six ou sept je crois
avoir la moyenne et g16 note en dessous
de 5
y'a rien ça vous fait rire olivier
pendant que vous vous amusez les autres
avancent la course a commencé vous vous
êtes toujours dans les starting blocks
vous accumulez les obstacles ya un monde
de l'autre côté du périph et vous y avez
votre place mais je parle à des gens qui
font semblant de m'écouter semblant de
me regarder
je suis là vous vous voyez est ce que
vous me voyez je peux savoir ce que vous
faites de boue mélanie j'ai pas fait
rêver des mcr de cantina il va être 11h
jeu prairies non fallait y penser avant
ok je mange comment moi c'est pas mon
problème les autres font comment les
règles sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
je m'en foutais règle ce que j'ai dit
n'attendez pas une réponse parce que ce
n'était pas une question en rose en ai
rêvé rien la faute si je bouffe ni un
commentaire vous avez tort j'ai raison
asseyez vous viendrez pas voir la fin du
cours asseyez-vous